so it begins I believe there are answers  in the sky up there is where I have  found the greatest happiness  gentlemen to predict the weather could  save hundreds of thousands of lives we  are scientists not fortune television  you'll get your chance they'll realize  your work I think they know my work  quite well enough prove them wrong James  I'm a really good aranaut I want to use  what I'm good at  women do feelings and thoughs and she  makes such a show of herself miss Wren I  need to make studies of ya I'm not a  coachman for hire you are the only  person who could fly us higher than  anyone has ever been so will you  side begins  [Music]  don't you wish to be up there with them  some reach for the stars some push  others towards me  [Music]  [Applause]  whoo that's get wet is this balloon not  the strongest that's ever been even so I  can't fight the weather  I have a feeling they're not coming back  we are traveling into an unknown  stay light  [Music]  [Music]  you